yeah so today I'm going to talk about
something that's just really exciting to
me and it's open source product that we
build at Stitch fix I'm going to talk
about how you can build scalable future
engineering with Hamilton
so if I want you know I want you to take
home a few things from today
um I'll try to convince them
first I want to convince you to
maintaining future engineering code is
difficult
it's because future engineering code not
looking into a loop where the
maintenance of it costs more than the
building of it so you're kind of
treading water
how is it the framework we built can
help you escape that Loop and Hamilton
is easy to get started with and easy to
use
cool so first things first
um Hamilton is open source code real
easy to install real easy to get started
with uh you can install the pipefi it's
also on Honda
um
you can get started in less than 15
minutes we've got plenty of
documentation online and lots of
examples so this is probably the most
important thing
right on the agenda today first I want
to start off with a motivating story of
data science King this is uh
to that one
okay this is
perfect you're good yeah if you have any
questions you can drop me a little um
right so on the agenda today let's start
with a motivating story of data science
so I want to talk about why we created
Hamilton in the first place and sort of
the difficulties of data science
communication skills
then I'm going to talk about Hamilton
the solution to their name and how we
built it sort of what its core
principles are
next I want to talk about our Hamilton
about sort of scaling up featuring
hearing and how we can help them by
scaling two things we'll get into this
later but it's not just failing in the
Computing data sense I'm really
interested in scaling sort of the human
being so as the business gets more
complicated you can still maintain as
these headphones finally I want to talk
about open source progress and next
episode
so let's dig into the data scientists
who are suffering
but first I'll give you a sense of the
uh scene we're in the company that I
work for called Stitch fix
it's a online personalized styling
service so there's two ways to attracts
you create your style profile and this
gives us sort of basic information about
you and a good sense of what will fit
you then a silos yeah either you can go
these sort of automatic subscription
route you'll put a personalized style of
person where they give you five handpick
items that are tailor-made figure Taylor
chosen to fit you and you keep what you
like and send back the rest and sort of
enter the process we can learn from that
or you shop at your own personal online
period store check out what you like you
can come you can return it if you want
uh the interesting thing about this I
mean you might be like okay clothing
this makes sense but why are you
speaking at a data conference right data
science though Powers every bit of the
user experience and it's all highly
tailored and optimized so selecting
which clothes to show this dialects for
them to choose for you is all done by an
algorithm optimizing Warehouse patterns
uh managing predicting merchandising
throughout five six 12 months in advance
all done uh powered by data scientist
and this has been incredibly successful
so far so we've got 100 data scientists
and data platform Engineers all of them
work on optimizing the
the optimizing the customer experience
I'm a data platformer engineer so I work
on building a tooling app for data
scientists and you can see we've written
about this quite a bit um I've read a
Hamilton post there uh but we write from
everything from everything from
uh data science sort of application that
models we've built to get a platform
it's going to be very open out there and
there's a few other things if you Google
the bloggers called multifread of coupon
if you Google it you can sort of read
about how it appearance fits
um all right so all I'm talking about
citrix's oldest model uh all this is in
the first one that they read that wrote
and until about too long ago uh was
still running in production and this is
the model to forecast the business so if
you want to decide what to do in a year
make plans for Staffing uh make plans
for what to build You're Gonna Want to
forecast how the businesses do it this
is understanding where demand might be
where science might be where trim might
be and what sort of capacity you need to
fill and
this is a fairly standard sort of type 2
machine learning problem uh you've got
your data coming into business actuals
uh then you sort of process that turns
into a featurized data frame a bit of a
bunch of Time series models predict the
future right so you use those time
series models to run a simulation
looking forward and then generate out of
data frame level four paths save that
somewhere in that certain symbol art
uh
so pretty standard thing I want to focus
in on the future evasion side right the
taking data from the business actual and
turning different features to your model
3 this is actually all modeled at
Hamilton and
um and you really it's basically meant
to be this whole thing but they
featurize pieces let's say something
two
this to the approach before Hamilton
came in was a bunch of operations on a
giant model with extensional data frames
so time was the key uh columns were sort
of like different signals do you want to
predict uh and there were like a
thousand to ten thousand but maybe even
more operations
um a lot of configurations that was
buried within business login so when you
want to model a fairly complex business
um
you need to be able to to switch the way
code can execute so there were a lot of
like nested about statements a lot of
functions that have sort of different
Behavior it was all buried within the
scripts and multiple layers of scripts
to execute store and visualize this data
and they had a world-class team of data
scientists around this
so
it worked fairly well
um but what got them there what got them
from starting the business with zero
forecasting ability to actually able to
forecast up here in advance of
reasonable accuracy wasn't going to get
the worst issues wanted to go we want
people to extend
s there are also simulations
uh quickly modified and run scenarios
and magnified block
so
there were quite a few problems with the
code and again I want to make it clear
that I'm not writing on the data
scientist who built this they were even
built just the right solution at the
time but as things go organically
there's a big hit right so unit testing
in this big models of script they have
ended up becoming difficult
documentation was a natural sort of
unenforced modularity not particularly
there is all sort of big Scripts
now that you can kind of loosely coupled
together but fairly tightly pull
together actually uh there's no real
data catalog so to figure out you have
to do a lot of gripping with like seven
places it's called was modified
to debug you have to run the whole
pipeline there's no way to just like run
one column and see what happens and new
data validation you're just like running
some last minute things on the table to
generate so the perfect initial solution
to forecasting problem is probably like
one script at first that solved
everything quite well plus a lot of time
three or four years ended up being
spaghetti code and
what happens when you have all these
problems and you want to start expanding
your models into new regions right you
want to say okay we're in the U.S we
want to really start forecasting in the
UK those first district is going
you want to add complex scenarios on
management player they're like what if
we pop some marketing for this specific
part of the business and you have a data
bug a variable time to solve it so
because of those previous things so the
answer is this wasn't fun they were kind
of drowning under this
um I don't want to say as a note this is
not actually a unique experience
District time series forecasting or even
pandas it's just a pretty General thing
right you start with something people
keep asking you and you Pace it which
you have to improve it have to make
changes to it is faster than the case in
which you can keep it happy and scalable
in that sort of like scaling your team
so this is a big problem we're trying to
solve
um I don't know about you but I can
relate to this I don't always write data
complex data pipelines but when I do
it's always in the call of
unintelligible math explanation
and I hope you guys don't relate to the
ideas are all better writing cleaner
native pipelines than me but it's but
start talking to Jupiter notebook
probably a bunch of code get
manipulations
get a production call today kind of lost
somebody else
all right uh the solution here was
Hamilton I'm going to talk about that
and how we sort of solve that problem of
enabling you to scale the pipeline
without making that CMS here
so we
aha moment the sort of first the the
thing we thought about it was the
driving Innovation Hamilton is pretty
simple actually it's one of every column
in this case column uh but it could be
more than a column if we just sort of
type objects with an artifact from your
data frame or from your ad data set what
is every one of those corresponded uh to
exactly one python function
and what if you could determine the
dependencies for the weight of the
Thompson was coded so in Hamilton the
artifact column in this case is
determined by the name of the function
and the dependencies are determined by
the parameter that's the core principle
right and if you've seen uh Pi test
fixtures or I mean Daxter has software
kind of artifacts that I can't after
this after we Outsource it uh it's a
similar idea right it's this
self-containing notion of fewer the
dependencies
uh so that you can get everything you
need to know from a function
all right so what does that look like
instead of writing into this old way uh
we're doing these with like simple
manipulations on data frames messing
around the columns you declare it in
this new way right so we've got a big
EFC equals D of a equals dfb DFD is on
transform on top of EFC instead we're
declaring c as a function it depends on
A and B you add them together and then D
now depends on C and we're transforming
right simple it's pretty easy to see um
again Hamilton supports all python
objects we're going to say most of the
differences for now
it's very kind of nervous so outputs are
equal to function then and the inputs
are equal to function argument right
this makes sense to everybody simple
cool
uh so what does the full hello world
look like like how do you get the stuff
running it's this much better
um you've got your functions
and you've got your driver and this
driver is the piece that actually tells
you sort of what when how it execute the
function is just the way the business
model so this decoupling of the driver
window functions is pretty key what does
the driver look like
but I'll report the driver and import
our functions are best feature Logic
instantially the driver passes some sort
of initial data or configuration after a
big symmetric of how this works for the
days uh there's a lot there that
Hamilton provides power with uh execute
your data frame so actually run it in
this case we're going to run CND and
print the result uh we'll get a data
frame of c and d and that's it right
let's go pldr we transform you write a
function functions declare a dag a
direct base of a graph if you know what
that is great if you don't that's
totally cool
um I think the point of how it is you
don't really need to know exactly the
stack the DAC is just a way of sort of
representing these compute flows data
structure and Hamilton handles that
so we are feature logic
we've got our direct basic work graph
and we've got our driver and together
this makes out the half of the Pipelines
all right so do
Hamilton and I'm not going to go into
all of it today but
the big question that people initially
say is like does this make your code
more verbose not only are you writing
functions uh but you're also writing
a single function for every sort of
columnar every output in your data
framework if you have a lot of them
and the first thing I push back is like
yeah I agree that's actually I'd say
that's actually not always a big not
always a bad thing right verbosity is
not the end of the world especially if
it's a trade-off for sort of like
cuddliness and management which I argue
that Hamilton really is
uh and you get all these benefits while
going through a bit um but when it is
two verbose we have a bunch of
decorators to sort of add metadata and
express them in higher level functions
so if you look early we have these like
this notion of assignment right so if
you have to equal CFC that's the sort of
basic concept of writing functions and
then we have the easy ways to sort of
represent other higher level programming
constructs so tag is a discussion
metadata parametrizing this is doing
Korean so it's kind of a for Loop right
for Loop setting a value extract columns
takes a data frame and represents it out
uh into multiple series one node for
each Theory check out quick is data
validation conquer.wins is kind of like
if else it says if the students
introduces all the time for region right
so if use this transform uh with these
dependencies it could be region is us if
the regions UK use these right so you
can start building code that is both
readable and very dry don't put yourself
but also but sort of gives you this sort
of real inspectability and real power
input and we're adding decorators all
the time I have to talk more about them
this is like my favorite feature of the
flashlight
so to summarize how this forces you to
write transforms and python functions in
a certain Paradigm and these python
functions provide everything you need
unit testing is simple you have final
python toxic
uh you can easily need to test them we
haven't yet but you can easily generate
their life testing steps to get you
started documentation use a doctor easy
enough modularity everything is by
definition into small pieces right so
function and the functions are organized
in the modules so there's a sort of
natural like hierarchical modularity Gap
to make a data catalog you can look at
the code as a sort of central definition
store so instead of searching your data
you're searching through the definitions
of your data this will correspond to
your data and all you have to do is look
for a column name if you want to figure
out a bigger artifact
who's bugging you can execute functions
individually or at break points one of
the really cool things is you can say
this this piece looks weird there's a
quantitative mess right here but
everything else looks good I'm just
going to run this run all the Upstream
pieces instead of rewriting the whole
pipeline
so data validation is included out of
the box and we have all sorts of angle
share exactly how that works and that's
actually so decorators provide sort of
powerful higher order operations to make
this less verbose if you're not a fan of
verocity and the driver allows you to
decouple the transform definition from
the execution
right and at Stitch fix it's been
running in production for three years
now
the usual use cases managed is 4 000
plus probably five or six thousand
features by now our data science teams
love it um boarded
uh We've enabled the monthly model and
feature update process for them to do it
four times faster so they're so that's a
big win
um it's just a very a much simpler
process now
it's easy to onboard new team members
they can be like this code is natural
theory for people who haven't even seen
it before code views are simple uh you
can use whatever changes and functions
and understand how your data and the way
it's created at this bank over time you
find the opinion tests and we actually
Auto generate space documentation so
they have now learned perfectly fine
documented now there was Button using
these options
a little visual on the left is you can
see I've just been still so we help them
write it initially for this use case uh
I have written the most commits because
I'm like a small private Tech guy but
Jason there has written far more lines
in this dialogue with a bigger
so this is the one on the left side is
that we've been sort of handing off and
working with the data science team very
closely but they really like it on the
right side this airplane is a
visualization of a part of their dag
where it's colored according to like
some sort of tags they have so it's a
really fun one all this is to say is
that it's just like really complicated
but it's a slightly simpler sort of
slightly nicer way of visualizing it and
they've done a lot of other work that
are visualizing and understanding how it
works
we can find the diameter of this yeah
which is pretty
pretty steep compared what I've seen
Seth
any questions about Hamilton before I
jump into scaling applications yep it
seems like you could do like other
things like you could bring like iPads
what's up
yes so this is a really nice way of
building today yeah it is
um we our first use case was teachers
like we even put it in a web service at
some point right you can create you can
tell okay the request is coming in we've
had an asynchronous driver around so if
you like pipeline these things and
optimize it people have done some pretty
crazy stuff with it because it's really
like a nice way of building bags
um the higher level functions we have on
top of it and towards like featuring
appearing involved creationism
yep I assume you get the visualization
of your dad it's like out of the box oh
and still yeah the question the last one
was can you do more with future
engineering Central model creation or
anything
yeah so um visualization yeah
we've got a visualization feature in
execution I'm sure later
um but it's also flexible
yep you want to return more than one
thing from uh more than one
Call of Duty yes if you want to return
more than one output more than one call
more than one data frame again it's a
pre-general purpose act framework we
have the notion of this driver decoupled
from the way that the way you define
functions so you can kind of do anything
you want or we have some simple ones to
get you started with the base use cases
but you can easily get more complicated
and if you don't want to put Jordan in
the data frame we have a way to just
like go to the dictionary results
yep yes but maybe this is what the dag
is for but if for example like in 100 of
the columns that you're generating out
of however many thousand
it involves merging two data sets is
that something that can be like done
once for all 100 of the columns that it
will generate or will that merge happen
every single time yeah so the question
is if you if you're doing a similar
operation such as a join for everything
will it runs at one time I mean that
actually depends on how you set it up
but you can be like
the incentives are aligned to make it
all happen at once because you can have
that uh you define that as a singular
node and have everything to come back
I'm unfolded so yeah I want more and
then where you're at all how do you use
a cyclone pipelines
um with Hamilton it's just like a
missing value imputation or one hot
encoding that's something you would do
afterwards or after Hamilton it could be
part of Hamilton it could be done after
Hamilton I would say that if I could
learn pipelines are like a pretty nice
low level conference we would fit it
generally within a halogen function or
break it up you have sort of really
focusing right save your questions for
the anime I'm told that I'm using this
love so I will uh as I'll get on to the
next piece and then put remember happy
dance and I'll be around afterwards
okay so we'll talk a little about
Hamilton features and again as we said
it is not a it's not restricted feature
in here but this is the area that we
most use it for
uh let's look at the machine language
something I think about a lot like well
the machine learning platform doing
Stitch fix but you got controverization
you've got training you got inference
let's focusing on februization that's
loading data and transforming the
features and again you can follow the
entire ml workflow at Captain we did the
initially space and we did I've seen
like quite a few others that do that
we're going to focus on bigger addition
so Hamilton works for any python
objective we're going to try and drive
this home uh and the building is
compatible or an angular python run so
orchestration systems such as airflow
people have Metabolic Effect uh flight
from daxer it's already trivial to
integrate so all you have to do is run
your tablet with data set there
um we have other ways we think about the
variant too and web services
so uh to model future relation what do
you need to write well you've got to
write your functions to load data you
got to write your transform and feed
your functions and then your driver to
materialize data and you can execute
only what's needed
so load your data this is extracted ETL
transform it create your features
write your driver to materialize it
as data alert is future function of the
driver and execute just what you need so
we need that lock on there let's get all
the Yellow Sub and the letters
and so okay pretty simple this is how
you pass and why is this hard generally
I want to say the answer is scaling it's
a hot letter answer the scaling
described everything like scale that's
cool um
so yeah um so scaling and again what do
I mean by scaling well I'm talking about
scaling in two different ways so the one
that I'm really interested in uh I'm
curious to see if you all are interested
in as well is the notion of is there
scaling to match Humanity encounters
so how does it meant to solve this
specifically uh this is a handle like
highly troubled code uh Google keep
debugging it understanding data flows
messy collaboration on complex pipelines
and validating your data Hamilton was
built specifically to solve this problem
but obviously the compute challenges not
everybody has small data that they can
run their laptop so there's a big memory
we'll have a bunch of parallel
computations they they want to use and
how is this not going to leave you uh
dry there Hamilton has Integrations for
this
um and the power of Hamilton is they
would advise and the coupling layer so
you can decumble a scale of your compute
how did the scale your compute from the
actual functions themselves to a decent
extent
all right so how do we see how first how
does it help scale the humanity right
um also talk about it we can help them
help you decouples of code so you can
double code from the infrastructure uh
the driver handles the execution and the
functions themselves handle business
logic so if there's a naturally within
the code
uh and as you can see you can run these
same modules in a bunch of different
drivers depending on about your driver
configurations depending on how you want
to run it right what sort of different
ways you want to run it
and with platinum on
and you definitely code for itself so
code is organized in functions functions
are organized with the modules and the
functions actually don't know about them
right they're just plain old python
confidence so they're portable reusable
anywhere
um if you run all your panel bin code
and you're like yeah I don't want to
count them but I like my functions you
can copy them over it right here get all
the procedural stuff
aside from a few specific examples but
it's all pretty affordable
but Hamilton makes it easier to debug so
to sort of knock your bugs out you can
screw around the broken paths python
functions makes it really easy to do
unit tests and natural debugging uh Pi
at home and gives you runtime data
quality checks for free I'll follow item
just a minute and it allows you to
quickly mirror the search space of data
bugs so if you've ever had to deal with
the data bug in your pipeline like some
weird thing that Cascades down you can
do a binary search of the day and you
can also see like you're good to do like
a bisect over the shape of the bag and
like my research over like all these
different spaces
it helps understanding individualizing
so you can visualize the data flow and
execution path is getting at that
question yes earlier here's like the
actual guy one of our world examples uh
you clearly track dependencies so
that's a collaboration um so Hamilton
serves as a central feature definition
store um what I mean by this is that
everything is graphical and you can
figure out the way it's generated from
the name of the artifact
this is an interesting thing where it
forces alignment I'm making so if your
function is declaring an upstream
dependency and those have to be the same
name so you're going to start thinking
more you're going to see the same device
and start thinking more about how to
name it I think this is really
fascinating because maybe is the hardest
problem in computer science and
everybody who Compares it to the thing
with all the mouse Cyclones are going to
be hard
um
but
the documentation is included in natural
python options and you can minimize
conflicts when collaborating because
everything's sort of globalized to the
specific business
change management feature versions are
hit all the changes already of history
and PR's are easy to read you really
Trace their changes back to the
functions
how we handle data validation
and but the big problem that we see is
governing every time right so if at any
point in your pipeline something's
looking bad then the whole thing falls
apart it doesn't matter how well tested
a lot of things are if some real estate
is broken so yeah how do you build
reliable pipelines today that the answer
is obviously you can't
uh
the solution here is that we've come up
with is runtime data valve is using
runtime data validation member here so
you can see here um I hope this makes a
lot of sense just looking at the code
that somebody we care about we say yeah
the data type is going to be the closest
before range negative one to one allow
man's not loud and importance is
performance it doesn't actually pay a
lot but it'll print out in your head
marks you should
sort of working on callbacks there
um so we have a few basic checks that's
what I showed rain and checks valid
categories and a lot because I'm like a
ton more and that's a nice portable
framework that we have to with open
source competitions
uh and those are companies and
Primitives but it's highly flammable we
want to like extend this out so it works
with a bunch of different things about
different institution Frameworks
and then there's something more powerful
if you guys are familiar with
uh Pandera and and Eric and Hamilton are
informed like really nice powerful
attacks you can give this whole data
first time for your data you're loading
from the warehouse and then it will fail
with the beautiful errors of Panera
and it's like super extensible um I
probably err on the side of making my
code like overly extensible
so use a base class you can write your
own you do whatever you want and we want
to add a lot more so we want to add
Integrations of any type of data Frame
data type I have a support or whatever I
imagine multiple they have data
validation framework so you can imagine
gratifications DQ we talked about why a
lot of folks and this guy's the limit
here we're all time values that's the
only example I can think of
kind of storytelligible
actually sum it all up why would this
helps using scalability commitment I
want to share
some code
um and the goal of this is that you
should be able to look at this code
and if you're familiar with python this
should be fairly obvious what it's doing
if you're not though like Michael like
my goal is to get it so like anybody can
read this right in a way that
um python did to programming where it
just became like that much for English
and that's more readable I want this to
view for like python data so what this
says is future climate normalized owned
by the client recommendation team could
say it's no personal identifying
information is a pet quote and the two
of three features have no name values
increase the values in that range
Version Control System configuration
over time and get the code base
production system
all right um so I have to adore you with
the scaling things components that are
really excited about uh
and if you're looking to sort of get to
the big KSI we'll get there in just a
second so how do you scale and compute
in the data using captive
well a few different approaches but the
main approach here is the delegate so we
have some pretty extensible ways of
doing this and talk about how we've
integrated candles with Ray and vasque
to parallelism and with errorism maybe a
Hamilton with brain faster parallelism
and pandas on spark um but there are a
lot of different regressions we're going
here so this isn't about this one's sort
of a call to action
rate ask allows you to run parallel take
a and they also a system so the pills
inside uh take a single machine spill
out a multifrocessing and scale out into
a cluster patterns and sparkilizing
scale horizontally from data set now
this used to be called koalas and
they've integrated and
sparkling method
and switching only requires changing uh
so yeah switching should be easy
it should only require changing driver
side code
and
except for handling Sparkle changes
which requires to deal with the data
letters and codes but pretty simple I
would be modular everything so stealing
would break here's our basic driver
we're looking at um this should be
familiar earlier because we like this
you can see that our data loaders our
data features our spent features there's
sort of like dates
marketing spent
and we executed the saved up a little
bit so ETL uh what does this look like
well we're importing the Hamilton Ray
thing initialize your array client
create this graphic applicants which is
a powerful abstraction I can call you
how to actually
execute this and how do you sort of
crawl the dag and run
we can then join it all together as a
panda's data frame and we've got this
and we pass that and grab backer into
the driver to run finally shut it down
if your resource it back to your friends
what does this look like a desk uh
important we can import the half a mask
say if you'll create a Das client pass
that into the desk raft adapter pass the
desk graph adapter into the driver run
your stuff shut down the client and give
the resources back to your friends
and Amazon Spark
so again this wouldn't be one that's a
little more complicated because the data
the the like object of the data types is
going to be slightly different for the
suggestion for the initial pieces
um but will you get create your spark
session Etc
um
run create your spark wrap adapter you
want to pass it a spine because
basically no index to join on
uh you've got your driver which takes
that in and the only difference is now
if it's in the spark data loaders
instead of the Panasonic loaders this is
so you can get in the right object so it
can sort of work down the screen the
cool part about this is the only
rewriting that one but it's an awful
okay the quality effect is over and
we're looking at sort of mode
integration as well which will solve a
similar problem in that it's a easier
way forever and finally stop the clock
session uh let your computer
so
how does this work uh we've got our
functions we've got our driver
and we then create our dags thing as
usual
and we end up delegating during that so
it's actually this simple right uh Acres
call back promote and that's delayed
allows us to sort of crawl to gag
writing in there and running everything
we need from parallel
right we're Hamilton and Spark how does
it work uh same deal except you change
the spark canvas equivalent options
instead Sparkle take care of the rest uh
run it we then sort of like a submitted
spark and you're a bit like running out
of Sparks beginning
so we're pretty excited about this um
but definitely some caveats for zero
they should use a serialization
methodologies they delegate the
underlying Frameworks uh memory the
default should work but fine to me at a
function level is not yet supported by
the dependencies you need to manage them
um that's obvious we're really looking
to graduate these apis from experimental
status so we use our want to hear their
health extensions if you have just the
right Paradigm um but we do not make
sure we're keeping up to date because if
you sort of high data community and best
practices to scale it so it's like
talking with Jeff and some of the staff
and I think it has been a sort of voice
do that but we want careers
okay so to wrap up uh let's talk about
open source progress and next steps
all right uh progress it's still it's in
early stages of a very thriving
community so multiple high profile users
we have IBM government services British
cycling team which is awesome
here like that the Federal Reserve uh
Pacific Northwest Natural Laboratories
statistics and a bunch of others
670 plus Stars we GitHub now a growing
set of four contributors and we're
looking for more contributors but my
various music feedback so anybody who's
interactive with it that's going to give
a sort of value at work next
I really believe in investing in open
source answered a lot of like things
that the biggest company should also
benefit
and what's our vision for this like
where do we want to get it to so I think
it can be the unifying layer for machine
learning etls I want to be able to
compile to an orchestration framework uh
so you might be familiar with dagster
prefix is talking right over there as
well in other rooms and store Apache
airflow metaflow no reason you couldn't
write API and Hamilton and use the like
really clever underlying orchestration
mechanisms of these taxes here and you
can even be writing uh your entire set
of functions and sort of break the dag
in just the right way to break the like
airflow pieces through medical pieces
giving you a really clean API on a
plural execution layer
and this isn't even counting the other
ways of running python so like Ibis
holders
Etc I think there's some nice inherion
that are wrong
we're going to be integrating with data
quality vendors of certain options uh so
you could arise it's more of a big
company thing about why logs I'm really
excited about it because it's a very
natural thing like whenever I got an end
one we met with them because we could do
that yet but that's something or applied
for contributors
we wanted to particularly load from a
variety of Upstream sources so get your
data in from Snowflake created income.pb
and then add SQL support right so I
personally believe in most of the stuff
you want to do you can do in Python
but there are some things that are very
simple that are very simple required um
and Deputy is sort of like really cool
because you can create to be like python
pandas SQL uh Gap there and you have
transfer you've got loaders.pb we've got
whatever pandas so we want to be able to
add that too as well and make it so that
you can kind of like DVT at a SQL node
in inside from the school
uh string that we then capitalize and we
can run is equal
and how are we getting there um so we're
adding new decades all the time I'm
working on one now we can reuse a sub
tag so if you have some big sort of set
of functions that you want to run for
like five different configurations all
in the same deck and managed to enable
that in a way that's nice and readable I
have multiple SQL support as I said and
please give ideas here or some otherwise
people who have sort of ideas to do in
this case we're figuring out how you
have like a thousand features not to
have a thousand dependencies but instead
of collect them all into Data
and more informative execution
um obviously more visualization better
that's just an imperative heart problem
uh
we compilation of data flow
specifications that's what I was getting
earlier a nice user interface perhaps
and more ideas we would love to get we'd
live enough tickets
and so even more than a try with your
feedback to start GitHub surveying and
stars
um Green Road issues during some Slacker
by slack Community uh
and all this stuff I'll get this life
after a little bit
and yeah oh sorry they event this
Thursday that reminder was like oh you
guys can eat in the rooms it would be
crazy over there
but it's a good reminder
uh and thank you um if you have any
questions I'm here now I would love to
answer them you can help me online I'm
clear connect with me on LinkedIn GitHub
and uh my emails
[Applause]
oh that was awesome so we'll probably
have more questions
um let's see we have five minutes for
questions so let's go here
I'll be around afterwards too
um so let's say I had
um a column is there any way you can
actually backfillment training
and and the second part and the second
question is let's say I have two columns
no is there any way they can go on
different schedule like one can be a
daily weekly or something like that the
second one first but that's an easier
question
uh yes you can run to a different
drivers in different days right so it's
a configuration that you have in the
execution mechanism that you pass in you
can choose what to run and then you're
not that different ways in terms of back
filling it's I would say Hamilton as it
currently is like slightly lower level
so I would love to say like I'm pretty
confident that we can figure that out
it's a matter of how you merge in you
know the day you pass in kind of
configuration to make sure you can do it
because it also didn't have the like the
validity of capture dating you get
whether you're getting time in the
kitchen
probably done
oh
great presentation thank you this may be
kind of an obvious question but what
happens when you showed the checkout for
death later and yeah you provide a range
of
values for the parameters what happens
when the brains violate that's what
happens so yeah you have two choices uh
there's failure and warmth so either it
logs an error and you can read that out
in your statements we have I think we're
adding the ability to call back soon
because you can like add it to the
Callback if you select fail then it will
error out um right now I think it'll
error out when it comes at first but no
reason to care about the very end of my
mind as well uh so you can use
any other questions
would you uh sort of this uh subjects
did they hire you specifically to be an
open source developer and like what's
their motivation for open sourcing stuff
that they are putting all their own
resources into yes they do not hire me
to be an open source developer
specifically they hired me to build out
their machine learning platform we have
a bunch of blog posts on that
the motivation is to hold the culture is
very open and there's not too much
secretive so there's high value and you
can get a lot from the outside world
middle graphic which is Big recruiting
one that was a big thing started
um
and also my personal motivations now
of course
hey uh what do you find is typically the
dividing line in Hamilton of you know
what's reasonable for a data scientist
to kind of write in the course of their
normal like model implementation or
feature engineering versus stuff that
more like data platform engineers and ml
engineer like like I look at some of the
decorators and the addition of metadata
like where's where do you find that
divide existing parts that are like
super approachable or that data
scientists think about maybe stuff that
I'm like that makes sense but I would
never have thought about it
so the I think the goal is to make the
entire API very data science friendly I
don't want there to be anything in there
that's complicated the piece that is
complicated is when you start to get to
the driver and the execution hood and
plug it into your infrastructure that's
where you'll leave like more of an MLB
or software engineering platform type
background but that's also what we want
to add into effect
your question about the so during the
inference how does Hamilton help you or
uh that is there a way like
recommendations for speeding that up on
the infrared side when you have to do
future transforms
so I see this question here in a few
ways you mean when you have to rewrite
your feature transfer pipelines in a
different setting
an extra year do you mean actually like
be modeled in for instance yeah like
like you have a user request that
contains some features that you want to
transform use the handles and kind of
functions
is there any recommendations to
record yeah so in terms of optimization
like literal authorization we can
delegate to the underlying Frameworks
but houses it's all sort of portable
code right so this is built for epls but
easy to sort of take and Skip and
anything
so you can say like okay I have this big
complex transform here where the
features comes in uh rerun that dag
eating productive in your microservice
where you're serving your Model results
and have another node that's actually
the model right so like load that have a
person load from the model from the past
um
and then how to pass all the way through
oh awesome let's thank our speaker again
[Applause]